the game is going Oh weird I just don't
see it let me take another look okay
sorry we have take off
efore e5 Knight f3 Knight f6
oh I don't like this opening choice from
Swift although a lot of would play solid
he brings the knight out he doesn't take
the pawn on but so far this looks this
looks pretty standard by both players I
do expect her to play Knight Knight to
f6 here ah
Sonny just giving a a e5 here yeah this
is a free pawn for Ludwig I'm expecting
a lot with caked upon no P goes for h3
he was worried about Knight g4 meaning
that he probably didn't see you v since
that would have protected that square at
the same time so now we have a chance to
defend it okay okay so now what we can
take the pawn again true at least
there's rook e8 which seems like it
could be tricky at the least but I think
black is probably okay in fact black
might even be better there but Ludwig
plays pawn to d4 which i think is
actually not a good move because now
black can take the pawn and move the
rook to e8 and black creates a lot of
threats in the center part of the board
right so he has to play accurately here
but I think it makes sense to take the
pawn if he moves the bishop back then
he's just giving up a free pawn so I
think you'll see that since the two
threats are very direct here yeah I
think I think pawn takes pawn as' is
obviously the best move but it's it's
not so it's not so clear to see you can
also take with a bishop here mm-hmm
which he did go for it so we're just
gonna see some trades and after the
Queen goes on to d4 I wonder if you'll
see knight c6 developing with tempo
right it's a very good move Knight to c6
rook e8 or probably the two best moves
here for for black so he does play it
okay good move
okay Queen t2 so he's blocking his own
dark-squared bishop and I'm worried
because his king is still in the center
of the board so any moves like rook e8
maybe even taking right away actually
seem kind of tricky to deal with yeah I
think black is clearly better if I mean
a swift or seize the idea bring the
brook to the center of the board and
putting pressure on the pawn on e4 I
think he's gonna be in very good shape
here
um he plays d6 which is also a
reasonable move because he just wants to
develop the bishop so that's far it
looks looks pretty pretty normal now
white is maybe very slightly better
possibly because he has two bishops but
neither side really can claim much of an
advantage and the way swifter is playing
makes me feel like he's more focused on
his own plan and what he usually does
than trying to see what Ludwig is doing
and see if he can take advantage and
capitalize on his mistakes right and
that's I think one of the hardest things
for these players who are relatively new
to the game is to Rosie if you look at
your plan but also what your opponent's
doing it's not just simply my plan and
that's it and that's one thing that
differs I think from that differs a lot
and Trust from a lot of other games that
you have to be aware of what your
opponent is doing as well it's not
simply I have the straightforward idea
because there is there is basically no
RNG in chess it's it's more or less
about just playing the best possible
music well that's why Robert has told
you good skill not good luck and you
roasted him hikaru Robert Haas pro gamer
ya chat never forget never forget
okay so 95 I like how he's playing this
he didn't see the main idea with putting
pressure on the knight in the center but
he is finding very nice squares for his
knight hopefully he'll develop the
bishop as well at some point yeah so I
like that they put the Knights the
center of the board attacking the bishop
Ludwig looks very very calm very very
focused and he's concentrating quite a
bit here
he doesn't seem as oh dude come up do
500 subs that's what Chat told us oh man
oh my god
no we got to take the bishop take the
bishop
you
okay that was that was a little little
tough to see and we get so focused I
can't even tell from his expression if
his camera stopped working or if this is
actually what he's thinking
okay well we can't take a look on
history move my queen
so my bishop can move and my queen won't
lead it get blind leading the blind I'll
just do that that's fine it's not like
you can do anything crazy it's kind of
choked off blind leading the blind that
was good I don't even know what a good
move for him is I feel like I should
move my knight here actually I'd be
great why didn't I do that thought I'm
an excellent I can still do it
no I'll just take me no I don't know if
he played Queenie to to develop his
Bishop on the dark square or if he saw
the threat I think he probably saw the
threat ain't trying to trying to protect
the bishop but I'm not sure I really
don't have a strong way about
okay now I'm lucid bishop good move this
is quite good by the lovely very gentle
soothing music in the background there
[Music]
stop friending me I don't want to be
your friend on chess talk haha what what
made you think I'd want to be your
friend
hideous pecker someone turned off his
notification poor hideous hikers thrown
under the bus oh gosh
stop threatening me
how is everybody frightening me Chester
come help a lot of pictures of Hikaru
that's pretty funny um they're
distracting him a little bit and this is
a big match for him because it's a bet
he put on the line yeah so far so far I
think in position remains very balanced
I don't think either side has much been
advantaged but again both players were
using a lot of time here which will be
important down the road as they get
further in the game yeah I was gonna say
though you need to move quicker he's
using a little bit too much time yeah
and that's the issue we saw in his last
game as well I think he just gets stuck
around this stage and it's tough okay so
he's trading off hopefully you'll see
that his rook is under attack here see
six way twice what's gonna work a fee
he's just shaking aside maybe he's also
getting a lot of friend requests
possibly just too many friend requests
for both the Blair's
huh I mean he just has to move his rook
over and he's fine or even block it that
might weak actually blocks with the pawn
he's probably doing very well but
pushing the pawn then Bishop goes back
he gonna push the pawn to e5 to try and
tack that Bishop on b3 that would be
very strong but it's very very hard to
find in this sort of a situation yeah
absolutely
but I remember he sat for maybe like two
minutes in the last game where he made a
big blunder and I think you just end up
getting tunnel vision you remind
yourself don't give this piece up but
then you over think for a position you
realize oh my gosh I spent so much time
I have to move then you make a move and
then you blunder it it's stressful
stressful chess situation rebby played
rook b8 which is also a completely
reasonable move and Ludwig goes f4 very
strong move Ludwig is moving really
really fast and scheme just you have to
like cuz you have to go out on a date or
something like he's moving really really
quickly well I don't know um I mean it's
not okay I'm gonna stop making jokes
about my earlier mistake f4 looks like a
good move um I I think it was you who
said last time he either makes
incredible moves are just really bad
ones right wait this is can fit wait
what's with this cam oh yeah he just
yawned so hard he broke the camera
really great exactly okay so anyway
though he's doing pretty well he's he's
up a lot of time on the clock he's got
nice pitches in the center I think he's
in very good shape here honestly
somebody should clip that and help him
make an emote from it instead of the
usual omegle all right exactly yeah yeah
for sure it's a 96 so now now Ludwig
Ludwig he's doing very very well here
should probably push the pond to attack
the knight as well but but he's actually
no he's not thinking he's just refusing
to think very interesting yeah because
he's only you he has like less than a
minute from when he started so plenty of
time b3 is actually a pretty decent move
because he can
his Bishop to b2 so he's continuing the
development here hopefully Swift Jerry
will try something like Bishop e6 even
trading off the Bishop from d5 I think
is good for him to get more trades off
the board just to have less likelihood
of blundering when he gets in time
pressure right so I think Bishop e6
would be an excellent move here for
Swift door I don't know if he'll spot it
again the position is really really nice
for blood with the two bishops on the
diagonals are just really gonna be
attacking down towards the black King so
I think in general this is looking
really really good for what I'm feeling
very confident for him that is fair his
Bishop is on b2 I wonder if he's gonna
go for a cheap trick with something like
Queen d3 queen d4 going for the mate
because the F pawn can't move in block
Oh
that wasn't good that was just a free
piece poof well it seemed so far like
Ludwig's 500 subs are going to be safe
yeah I think unfortunately there are
it's gonna be very hard for switcher to
come back as the bishops are just aiming
right down towards the king here so he's
got there's a lot of pressure he can
bring the other rook to the board and
the King just has no safety at all it's
just in a world of hurt yep the pawn on
g7 like you mentioned under attack
swifter on top of that low on time he
can't do defending moves like pushing
the pawn because he is pinned it's
honestly such a tough position to find
any decent moves in yeah it's really
really difficult here and I think Ludwig
Ludwig is in very good shape he's I
expect him to win this game here up
nearly seven minutes on the clock I
think at this point well six and a half
right now soon to be seven and no real
ideas for swifter and Ludwig has the two
bishops aiming right the king so I think
in general this is a very tough spot to
be in if you're Swift or yeah absolutely
and I don't know I feel like it'll be
tough so he will have lost all of his
games in the bracket mm-hmm
and you know we may have seen that
yesterday with Iran but of course he got
that pity when from voyboy so that
didn't end up happening but how do you
think his psychology is going to be
after this game um I don't think it's
gonna be affected that much because when
he lost the game too he lost a game to a
box box he was in a very good mood very
good mood after I came here Ozzy is
relatively new to the game he doesn't
have high expectations so I think
certainly in terms of Swift worries he's
got the right positive attitude where
she's like I'm just gonna try to play
good moves and see what happens rather
than thinking okay I should beat these
people or I'm better than them which is
really the attitude we should have since
he is so new to the game
that's foreign Chet yes he you know Iran
might not be winning in chess but he's
winning in life I mean congratulations
to him for his baby girl yesterday he
must be you know one of the feeling like
the happiest he ever has in his life so
focus on that chat it's more important
he did get aw yesterday though as well
he did that is true so just so many w's
all around
okay well I I liked rook a f-1 it's a
very straightforward move and just
continuing to put pressure on f7 um yeah
I think anything that where he doesn't
lose this rook here like rook f1 Queen
f3
there are many moves that are very good
here just let's find one of them right
as long as he doesn't make a blunder
like Queen g5 or rook g4 that might give
um black a bit of counter chances right
exactly yeah so I I don't expect him to
make a blunder like that but you never
know it is Ludwick he he can be very up
and down sometimes that's how he keeps
it interesting why don't we take a
listen on his stream again so then if I
move my Queen here to block that and
then he does it anyway right let's just
say for example I moved my queen here
and then he takes his Bishop I take with
Queen then he gets a free rug so then I
could block with her up to that he just
takes a bishop I could just move my King
straight up
but that seems lame and weird
I have no idea I got nothing there you
go very good my attack I'm not worried
about my defense my do I could get
checkmate on the back here what am i
that's miss yeah could be really whip it
out I think no clue really well I don't
know if he knows about this I assume he
does because he said it - I mean Bishop
takes h3 works but I guess I could have
moved a pawn for it not bright if he
sees it I just don't know if he's made
an eye - haven't seen him arrow it so
the problem is if Swifter does that and
he doesn't see it right so we did take
on e3 yeah he did see it okay okay think
about this think about this I take right
here he's seeing it he's in check he
must take
don't move your queen away keep
protecting that mate that's the only
thing that could go wrong here right
exactly yeah very important not to move
the Queen away from the pawn on g2
something like Bishop takes f7 rook
takes f7 and if he brings his Queen to
like c4 to attack again unlikely but
that would be one blunder scenario right
do you think in rapid chess it helps to
look at possible blunders just so you
don't accidentally fall into them yeah I
go quick
Queen to f3 and I get the triple the
legendary triple stack okay that was the
least clear response I've ever had in my
life I think certainly looking at
blunders is important generally I don't
approach that way I try to find the
absolute best move but I was too busy
being being awed by the triple legend at
the legendary triple stack no that's
fair I think my audio is a bit delayed
so to me it seemed like he wasn't
talking but okay we're back to our usual
board now Queen f3 so he's attacking the
bishop he's also putting more pressure
on f7 a very nice move yeah I'd love to
explain this game extremely well use a
little bit too much time there in the
middle perhaps but all the moves he's
played have been very very precise and
very very crisp and he still has five
minutes so even if he's taking a lot of
time now he played so quickly before
that it doesn't really matter right yeah
and I just think this is looking really
really good for for Ludwig looking
looking to win this game he looks very
primed to to win this and move on and
play against uh I think choco bars 5 if
I have the standings correct
alright choco bars versus literally that
would be an interesting matchup I don't
even know how yeah Ludwig is crushing
true he is just up to bishops but not
just up to bishops the defiles on the
black King are going to be open so he's
gonna be able to get some kind of crazy
mating attack and Swifter is under a
minute on the clock yeah I think this is
this is pretty close to loss or Swift or
at this point was down just the two
bishops I think I think this is this is
game over pretty much
who some some tough times
I don't know what to tell him other than
hopefully it's been a learning
experience also we got a raid from
Robert Hess who puts the Hess in chess
thank you so much Robert the house oh
don't get too excited guard isn't that
the thing or am I wrong
yeah yeah sure let's go with that no no
I got Chivas okay so you're right Ludwig
is definitely about I mean he has like
made in three ideas here if he sees rook
takes g7 and then moving the robot right
yeah he can create the the discovere
check with the checkmate here yeah a lot
of ways just on his way to victory in a
couple of moves here you move there yeah
I move vertices to checkmate immediately
and yeah very variable game absolutely
and I'm just gonna bring it back to the
first mistake the critical moment when
Ludwig ended up blundering a piece well
okay
Ludwig blundered his Bishop we both were
shocked
unfortunately Swifter missed it so he
had time to defend it and then what
happened was that we saw a blunder from
Swifter I'm just bringing it up when he
played when I takes f4 he must have
missed that the rook was defending it
and after that Ludwig just played
perfectly solidified the win there and
he's celebrating so let's listen to
Ludwig when I think we're ready now yeah
let's take a listen
or will even you can do it if me a man
who graduated with a two point nine six
GPA 3.0 if you include honors choir in
high school very well honors choir the
hardest class of them all two point nine
six nice you hung your Bishop in the
beginning if I look at my accuracy I'm
sure it's like above seventy two point
five and look at that is accuracy was a
little rough yeah unfortunately I mean
there were a lot of was they play that
game which weren't weren't weren't the
best music I thought overall he tried
he'd miss Mayton eight he tried to play
some moves that made sense unfortunately
opposition was quite tricky and I got my
nice hard to find them I was impressed
by Ludwig I thought we played was very
very clean right other than that one
blunder but if you don't count it very
nice attack at the end there his plans
were very straightforward and I think
that's what we've learned about him if
he doesn't make crazy tactics I get
punished she can't play a very solid
chess game right yeah totally agreed and
I thought in general the way Ludwig
played was very very it was very good I
liked it I thought it was very clean
game other than the one mistake and I
think this is why he's one of the
favorites in the consolation bracket
well let's take a look at the last match
of today so we are going to see xqc with
the white pieces take on hutch we know
this is a mismatch in terms of rating
and experience but hey XQ see has the
white pieces he's had some time to
recover from the previous chess games
which always helps when you have the joy
of the game back in there right
certainly yeah and I think X you see
he's had a little bit of time off I
think certainly I saw him playing chess
earlier so it's probably he's probably
getting ready doing some puzzles and
things so yeah I think he just needs to
be fresh be ready and I just going going
and try to play his best and let's take
a look at the brackets as well so after
this round we are gonna see Swifter
taking on slicker
I do think slicker is a favorite there
and Ludwig taking on chocolate bars and
we're a little bit might be a slight
favor
but actually it might just be very close
I'm not yeah I think if we look at the
brackets I I mean I would say they're
certainly our favorites I mean I think
the match is that the two matches that
are most evenly balanced I'd look at her
probably loaded with choco bars and and
I think Foose Lee xqc those are probably
two matches I would say objectively are
the most balanced but again anything had
happened that the rating ranges are much
closer here than perhaps some of the
matches involving like box box are
forced and when they were playing some
of the players at the bottom of the
group so I think there are some
favorites but it's going to be very very
close we are alive we are joined by
swifter or Joseph whatever you prefer to
be called you had a kind of a tough game
there you played a really strong opening
and then you blundered your night did
you miss out the rook could take yeah
yeah I I just missed that I was being
careful checking all directions and I
and I and I and I completely missed that
so you know
wow that was rough I I hate to bring up
something after the game but you
actually had winning chances where
Ludwig blundered an entire Bishop
earlier on I'm just gonna pull it up so
you can see it just so that you know for
the future not trying to rub in oh sure
I want to learn from it and I'll cry a
little bit off stream but yeah well I
just pulled it up on the board so after
he castled his Bishop was actually
hanging oh no I could have easily taken
that okay yeah I don't I don't know why
I didn't see that I think I was
I seem too much yeah okay yep yep yeah
well that could have been easy take your
car do you have any comments I'm trying
to read by your face there no no I'm
sorry yeah I I think I mean it was a
difficult game mainly because there were
only a couple opportunities where you
had moves it or logical after the
opening phase of the game but yeah
taking this Bishop was one option I I
felt that maybe you could have taken
advantage on the second one was also you
instead of moving the knight to the
center of the board if you go back just
like two moves right would you attribute
to c4 you could have brought your rook
to the center to e8 after why yeah yeah
but you know in either order where you
basically put a lot of pressure on this
pawn on the Sun Center before black gets
or before white gets the King out of the
center of the board so normally when
there's a pawn and center like this you
want to try to attack it if you can got
it got it oughta made a lot more sense
right right and I know specific moves
are really hard because obviously they
usually only play in specific positions
but I think the overall theme I noticed
with your opening is that you seemed
laser focused on your own plan without
really thinking about whether your
opponent's play has been creating any
weaknesses so you weren't really
reacting to what Ludwig was doing as
much no you're absolutely nice I mean
like just me not being flexible with
what I want to do for my first few moves
it's just like you know in my head like
this is what's safe and this is what's
gonna prevent me from like you know
losing in like you know four turns or
whatever so I stick with that but I
really need to learn like you know how
monitor what they're doing and and like
you said just like you know be able to
accommodate or a respond to like you
know what they're going for absolutely
right because you can continue with the
type of plan that you're going for but
also maybe if you I know you already
took up a lot of time so I don't want to
be here telling you to take more time in
the opening cuz it's so hard to play
with time pressure but you know just
general it seems like if your opponent's
king is developing much more slowly try
to see if you can put some pressure in
the center and and small things like
that might help but at the end of the
day it's just a matter of experience so
you know don't beat yourself up over it
oh yeah no I mean I feel like I've
learned a lot in the past week so I'm
just gonna gonna keep on play more games
and keep doing like puzzles and and just
just learn more some I'm definitely more
hype now than I was before to kind of
like I feel like I'm mad at brink where
I can actually be a human being
eventually
so so we're getting there that makes a
lot of sense I always love hearing
hearing your attitude here and we know
you're gonna be taking on slicker next
based on the new brackets any comments
on that matchup oh boy I know nothing
not the listen to this audio a bit more
but I'm excited to play see how it goes
oh my gosh when you laughed I couldn't
tell if it was new or hikaru laughing or
if you guys just morphed into one
megabyte same time Hikari do you have
any comments I just I think mainly yeah
like I like your positivity just trying
to learn and taking it all in stride and
you're playing slicker next I think I
mean you just just play well you make
some good moves and hopefully hopefully
you'll pull off the upset I'm gonna do
my best and are we gonna see you
streaming any chests on your twitch in
training or have you been doing mostly
offline I've been doing a lot of puzzles
on my on my stream and I guess one of my
viewers when I did try to do like a game
online well maybe was like you know
sniped me using the same saying the 10-5
settings and and I barely managed to win
off but I was almost very embarrassing
he had like a 400 rating sorry T man but
uh but yeah I mean I think I think you
know just practicing em I get a lot of
great feedback from my you know from the
viewers and and so that's great just
having that positive feedback so he cars
also getting a lot of positive feedback
from our viewers right now chat keep up
the hikaru spam you see well thank you
so much Joseph really appreciate your
positive attitude it always puts me in a
better mood honestly and I'm worried in
a good mood to start with so thank you
so much I appreciate thanks for having
me guys yeah take care thanks alright
chat we'll take another quick look at
the two brackets so we see Swifter he
finished fourth in Group D he's going to
be taking on slicker and Group C Ludwick
finished third in Group D so he's gonna
be taking on chocolate bars in Group
four so we do have one more matchup
today it is not going to change the
final standings but if xqc plays a good
game against hutch maybe you'll have
more confidence when he goes into the
well it could change the standings if if
xcc pulls off the upset it could she
who plays against boy boy Oh true true
yeah so if xqc does pull up with
standing it won't change it for xqc but
it will for who hutch ends up playing
and we got Ludwig here as you want to
interview me separately it was I gonna
get talking to I feel like I'm in
trouble
Ludwig Lloyd's why are you saying no I'm
just kidding um why did you give your
bishop for free though come on literally
you had 500 gifted subs on the line you
cannot be living life with that kind of
risk
Alex Alex Alex here's a little thing
that I'm gonna pass on to you from one
server to another
it's called throwing for content you
gotta make it a little more exciting all
right throwing a hanging bishop have
everybody in suspense for a moment my
end game is phenomenal do you know why I
picked up the vork shiki's endgame book
okay now I can't read a word of this
because it's all in chess notation it
makes no sense but I own it and this
alone has been a 300 point up for me Oh
have you been like sleeping next to it
trying to get some you know I don't know
every night I no longer own a pillow I
just sleep on - vork shiki's book at 4th
edition car you have you read it I have
actually yes I have it's just that it's
like so like that's like the last thing
I ever expected anybody in this
tournament to have so it's a 2200 level
players to become GM's
yeah I mean something would argue it's
even above that it's like even for
someone like me it's it's it's not easy
in front is very very advanced breezing
through it
I mean I'm mostly just flipping through
at the pictures play I'm learning a lot
very quickly yes so can you share the
part of the book that teaches you to win
and games down a bishop uh yeah so what
well what he says is you know what it's
actually really complicated we should
actually hold off a bit on this one
I do love where your head's at we should
hold off action on this one a bit but I
would be I would get it nitty-gritty yah
I mean anyway I want a game that's
Nations coaching I think I figured it
out
I got no coaching this weekend I want
again
I mean you know maybe it's just all on
you so did you actually bet 500 subs on
this game yeah 100% yeah to put a little
fire under my ass okay hey you know I
heard he car who's saying that oh I
don't really know he's gonna win this
game it depends on which side of the
bracket they want I have a lot of
integrity hikaru all right I always go
for the W mm-hmm III agree with that
yeah totally well congratulations for
your first we do you think how do you
think your game verse Chacko bars is
gonna go uh I have no idea is she good
did she win a game she's she went Oh in
four oh and three but yeah yeah yeah Oh
easy dub she had a very close game
versus liquor though could have gone
either way
yeah but it and you lost the slicker
well you know exhibition let's be real
okay you know it's so count to be clear
I'm feeling good about that my goal is
to make the finals against moist
critical that's my dream that is a
pretty big dream so are we gonna see you
a continuing to do some exhibition
matches or are you gonna just be reading
your new endgame manual on stream I mean
look I'm at page three right now it
takes me a long time to get through it I
have to bring up a chessboard and then
do every move I just learned about
opposition and so and so I just only
have 426 pages to go and once I'm done
with that I will be a GM I'm sure of it
hikaru you have any words of
encouragement there anything not
realizing you're amazing the things you
come up with her just so out of this
world and I never could predict you you
would you would buy that book that's
just it's it's just incredible man just
speechless yes
can you guys coach me finally oh yeah oh
for coaching at 11 a.m. I know and you
did meet her right you didn't even reply
to my message - I was so insulted that
you said 11 a.m. that I ignored it you
know I can't wake up before noon I'm a
streamer okay oh I'm gonna suggest on
lessons with choco bar afternoon and I'm
gonna prep you for her thank you I think
we're gonna do that's what we're gonna
little
for God's days all I ask Alex ok I love
it
I'm so sorry stood even he rusted any
what well Ludwig honestly this has been
a blast like it is every single time
you're on the show I mean you looked a
little bit like a villain during and you
kind of talk like one when you come on
as well but I think that's everybody's
favorite someone's got to be the villain
it can't all be nice new chess players
who are like oh it makes an l-shape yeah
somebody's got a gun for hikaru all the
way to the top oh ok exactly yeah yeah
no I like your confidence your attitude
and it's just today has been great to
see ever every day every time you played
a game it's been something something
different so I just spent a lot of fun
thus far and looking forward to seeing
you
go through go through the consolation
bracket and hopefully when it all I will
by the way we didn't forget we still
expect you to play blindfolded against
everybody in the tournament out 1c Cara
I'm gonna be doing it against 8 people
on like July 7 3 so definitely gonna
happen you wouldn't want me in there but
I'm just saying the way you're saying
that you totally have to be in there now
cuz you think that you think that I
can't beat you that you're you set
yourself up I mean I like you I love the
streams
alright longtime fan I just know that I
want you to succeed if you lose to me
well I'm holding I want to be a it's not
gonna look good amazed I ate okay
right save yourself I like your
confidence man Oh we'll see we'll see
I'll even throw in an eyepatch to make
it fair looking forward to it alright
guys thank you so much thank you so much
light away take care and good luck